another big television event happened
last night The scandivals Showdown when
I was 21 years old the Vanderpump
reunion exploded into chaos as Tom
Sandoval faced his Vanderpump co-stars
for the first time getting my face is
gonna you up look at me bro I'm way
more than you within the first two
minutes I did think oh gosh no way are
we actually gonna get through this you
know James starting off I will beat him
you actually won yep season 10 standout
James Kennedy all fired up and bringing
the drama you're a worm with a mustache
do you even remember the things that
came out of your mouth that day poo poo
head both of you poo poo heads people
have asked did that just spring to your
mind and I was like yes actually it
really did and this was wild I'm sorry
for
doing the one thing I said I wouldn't do
James's ex Raquel who had an affair with
Sandoval watched the taping from a
trailer a hundred yards away because of
a temporary restraining order she filed
against her co-star Sheena Shea oh no
Raquel sighed and seemed a little
worried Ariana's gonna unleash on you
it's her turn next Wednesday when part
two airs Ariana told E.T a lot of
emotions have shifted since the show was
shot two months ago it was where we were
on March 23rd I think mentally were we
to film that reunion today I don't know
if everybody would be on the same level
and one mystery Still Remains What about
rumors of a game-changing revelation
apparently there is something so wild
that's gonna be revealed in the reunion
that could potentially have you guys not
want to sign back up to be on the show
Raquel's pregnant I don't think so
Affair started during James and Raquel
era maybe Lisa knew the whole time I
don't think so Raquel hooked up with
Brock you said you trusted your husband
been to bed with it I did I don't think
so no no there's no way